Speaker 1: Let's go next to Lucas from Copenhagen.
Lucas, you're on the air.
Yeah, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: All right, cool.
Yeah.
I wanted to ask you something about fiscal
policy, especially right now with the new
administration in the U.S.
So from what I can tell, the spending of the
Biden administration is just blowing everything
that the US has ever spent really out of the
water.
And I've heard you talk a lot about how Republicans
only say, oh, we care about the debt, but
they're in charge.
They don't care about and fully get that.
But what is your perspective on the debt?
I mean, are you are you not worried about
the debt us amassing right now?
Speaker 1: So there's a couple of different
things here.
First of all, when you look at the debt, you
have to look at it relative to the size of
the economy.
So the first the first principle is just because
the debt is going up in terms of the number
of dollars, I'm more concerned with what it
looks like relative to the size of the economy.
If the economy keeps growing and the debt
grows proportionally, I don't see that as
a problem objectively.
That's number one.
Number two, Joe Biden did the stimulus package.
And then there's some other things that that
imply spending via executive order.
But I mean, you know, the tax reform hasn't
passed stimulus sorry, infrastructure hasn't
passed.
So other than covid stimulus, what are you
referring to?
Speaker 2: Well, I'm just thinking about the
agenda that some of the Democrats are pushing
for.
I get the sense that a lot of Democrats in
the U.S. want to sort of transform the US
into a social democracy and European style.
But for example, I live in Denmark and the
minimum tax rate here is thirty seven percent
income tax.
And I don't know if they have the guts to
to raise the taxes and spending that they're
going to do.
Speaker 1: So it sounds like you're assuming
that taxes have to be raised in relation to
the spending they want to do, but that's not
necessarily the case.
Speaker 2: But but the spending of the United
States has really increased a lot, especially
under Obama and under Trump.
Speaker 1: So it actually relatively so the
deficit actually went down under Obama.
It was still positive, which edged up the
national debt.
Trump did come in promising to pay off the
In one term, he actually accelerated deficit
growth.
I think maybe Lucas' the the problem is, you
know, you started with wanting me to comment
on all the spending Biden has done.
But then when I pointed out he's really only
done covid stimulus, he said, well, there's
a lot of Democrats who want to do spending,
which is a completely different thing that
hasn't passed yet.
And they'll have to present to us how they
will pay for the spending that they want to
do.
So we're kind of moving the goalposts a little
bit here.
Speaker 2: Yeah, but what do you then be in
favor of something?
For example, in Germany, they have a law that
you're not allowed to spend more than you
earn over two percent annually.
I mean, I get your argument, but would you
be in favor of something like that?
I mean, you know, I would.
Speaker 1: I wouldn't.
And I'll tell you why.
I'll tell you why I wouldn't be in favor of
that.
There are types of deficit spending that over
the medium to long term are deficit negative
and are economically stimulative.
And they are often a lot of the bigger projects
that I think would be important for the country
to do.
And so to to simply arbitrarily say you can't
go two percent in spending beyond revenues
when you might be able to do something that
would cost you net money in the first or even
second third year, but would be a big boon
to the country over the long term.
There's I don't see any reason to artificially
handicap the ability of our leaders to to
do things in that way.
I don't see the benefit of it, particularly
the more we learn about modern monetary
Speaker 2: theory, long term, something we'll
have to be done.
Right.
I mean, you can't continue on this path forever.
You do understand that, right?
I mean, I totally get your point.
Speaker 1: It's not clear to me, you know,
I mean, here's the thing.
It's not all economists agree that we can't
continue on this path forever.
Again, if you look
Speaker 2: at our monetary theory is really
something that that is highly theoretical
and being pushed by some of the new economists.
A lot of people disagree.
Speaker 1: Many people disagree, but understand
that many of the things that neoclassical
and Keynesian economics tell us are only slightly
older ideas, and they regularly fail to actually
function according to neoclassical and Keynesian
economics.
The U.S. should have should have seen over
the last 20 years.
Absolutely explosive inflation.
And it hasn't happened.
Why hasn't it happened?
Are you also going around saying all of the
neoclassical economic economists are wrong?
Speaker 2: No, I don't think so, but for example,
the interest rates have been very, very low,
so it has been it's been very cheap to take
on that.
But I think now that we are in so much that
it becomes very hard to push interest rates
up again to rates where we had them previously
of the financial crisis.
Speaker 1: OK.
And so what?
So then the inflation will come when?
Speaker 2: I don't know about inflation, I'm
just a student, I really don't know a lot
about the economics, but what I do know is
that the US is taking on a lot of debt and
so are countries in Europe.
And I just.
I can't see why that would be healthy and
the absolute long term.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's not I, I get the idea,
Speaker 4: but
Speaker 1: you seem to be applying sort of
like household economics to macro economies
and there's a lot of really good academic
scholarship about why it's just the wrong
paradigm through which we should be thinking
about it.
Speaker 2: Well, I would disagree, but I think
we're short on time.
I want to move on, so I respect that.
Speaker 1: Well, I mean, you disagree, but
you also said you're not really you don't
really know about economics, right?
Speaker 2: Well, I'm I'm going to study economics,
I don't really know a lot about it yet.
OK, I think I'm just sort of not really I'm
not sure where I stand yet.
OK.
Some people say that that is very dangerous.
Some people say we shouldn't worry about it.
Speaker 1: But then what?
Well, I think I mean, I think neither neither
of you is right that both of those are very
black and white views.
Debt doesn't matter or debt is very dangerous.
What increasingly seems to be the case is
that we have to apply a more nuanced view
and say taking on debt to do certain things
and in certain cases is OK, and then simply
increasing the money supply to pay debt maybe
is not so good.
Right.
So I think we just have to look at things
in a more nuanced way.
Speaker 2: Yeah, maybe we should, yeah, but
all right, Luca.
Yeah, yeah, thank
Speaker 1: you very much.
Appreciate the call.
Let's take a very quick break.
Don't hang up if you're holding, because when
we come back, I'm going to go right back and
talk to more people.
Standby